joining us now one of the best running
backs in the National Football League
first season with the New York Jets he's
Le'Veon Bell he's appearing on behalf of
pep coined by PepsiCo everybody loves a
payday including levy on a now everyone
in the country can get their payday with
PepsiCo's first ever loyalty program pep
poin when you buy Pepsi Co beverages and
frito-lay snacks together PepsiCo pays
you back today levy on will be driving a
pep coin armored truck around New York
City surprising fans with coin in
celebration of his paid a visit pep coin
calm for more info had you ever driven
and have you ever driven an armored
truck before today i honestly know so
this is the air plenty for me to is
there any special training for driving
an armored truck is it a stick shift can
you pop a clutch do you know how to do
all that
hey well it's good to have you for a few
minutes i know you're doing a bunch of
these monday night football that's the
buzz right now in the NFL everybody's
talking about last night's game i'm
always curious as a football player how
much of a football fan are you do you
watch a game like last night as a fan or
is it hard for you to enjoy it as a fan
because you play the game oh yeah i
watch the other fan you don't mean i
still have work like favorite players
that i watched around the NFL and
russell wilson is definitely one of them
so it was fun watching him Billy Dooley
did well last night it was such a fun
game entertaining game on both sides of
the ball though who are your other
favorite players
I like sake long I like it Atari killed
I like Zeke you Elliott I mean there's a
lot of exciting players you know I mean
I can go for days but I don't they'll
continue to leave people out you know
this was you mentioned you mentioned say
Kwan he had a rough day on Sunday and I
look at the stat line and I like my eyes
have to refocus surely it's not 13
carries for one yard you say anything to
him after the game to kind of you know
boost him up a little bit moving forward
uh yeah I mean we talked up to the game
and my baby told me he knows it keeps
keep moving for you know how you know it
was a good game you know so he's coming
back off the injury and things like that
so I'm sure he probably still fighting
out a little bit and plus you know this
team I'm having a little bit of
struggles kind of like we were a little
earlier you know we just was able to
overcome that game but I'm sure you know
they'd get back in the no right
situation get the [ __ ] still in the
right way you say football is a tough
game it's also a tough business that's
something that you learned a couple of
years ago what's the biggest business
lesson you've learned during your time
in the NFL the biggest I mean really
just stay patient you know the state of
course you know I've been playing
football since a long time so nothing
really came no overnight so I'm I kind
of had that mindset the whole time were
when I was sitting out the whole season
and I'm understood what I was trying to
do in but I felt like I was working at
the time so I don't know that's really
like I guess my biggest you know my
biggest when I was there one of the
things that drives me crazy living on
about the NFL game is everybody's
allowed to make business decisions
except the players and when the players
make business decisions are being
selfish they're being greedy they're
being this to being that how hard is
that to take a stand when it feels like
the whole system is rigged against
players making business decisions oh yes
you know what I was have a player you
just gonna gotta understand where where
everything's coming from you know fans
kind of you know like that certain team
or that city where they're from or
whatever it is you know they're always
were kind of we're not always little
majorities gonna side with know that
team just strict because they like that
team you don't think what that seems to
be the best that it be so sometimes of a
player you know once more
you know money or a better situation you
know the time looks bad
the player but a lot of times they don't
really understand you know where the
player is coming from so it gets a
little tough sometimes but I just like
you know understanding where I'm coming
from and I try to do it best for you
know my family or myself and I encourage
all done players do the same thing you
know it's amazing just here and you
explain that levy on it impresses me
that you have a very pragmatic very
even-keeled view of what can be a very
tough game a very tough business is that
just the way you've always been or have
you had to kind of get yourself to
understand you separate the emotion from
that calculated business angle that you
have to take if you're going to be
successful in this league um I mean I
think it's a little bit of both you know
me I think naturally my personality is
like I've always kind of been like a
stubborn kid you know so I think just
over time of course it's hard obviously
I've learned a lot as I've been in FL
but I've been they both kind of played
into it and it's like you know my
understanding has grown as I got older
you know in the league and I've been
around then obviously like it's not my
natural like personality a little bit
you know so my thing they both kind of
played a factor into it it kind of made
me who I am today you had a great video
a couple of weeks ago preaching patience
for this New York Jets team you're now a
part of that things are moving in the
right direction
give me the main reason the main thing
that you've learned during your time
with the team that causes you to believe
that this is an organization with the
arrow pointing up um yeah I've already
made that video just know because
everything's fun in the whirlwind you
know is LA people on social media and
talking about you know all types of you
know trades and and we know people one
get the coaches in GM it's tough fire to
things like that you know I didn't want
everybody really understand it you know
it really takes time to kind of build
the program which you're looking for you
know all the great programs you think
about it you know it took them time to
get to where they're at
you know and that's the direction you
want to go obviously so we got a lot of
good know creators over the offseason
and know we had a new coach and know
basically a whole new line and new
general manager so everything not gonna
just happen you know in the blink of an
eye you know I just wonder people trying
to understand that and you still had
that very calm dispassionate patient
approach even though you had just been
the subject of trade talks you mentioned
on the 17 weeks podcast from
uninterrupted that the Packers the
Chiefs the Texans the Steelers had all
expressed interest in trading for you at
the deadline how close did it come to
actually happening with one of those
four teams oh it was close you know I
mean I obviously was a you know at the
time just like hair and everything got
and seeing how everything plays out you
know honest I didn't want to get traded
but if it did happen you know I was
ready and I was you know obviously gonna
kind of do what I had to do but um yeah
other kind of Mustang you know um you
know from the Jets perspective it's
nothing worth a you mean they got some
value out of it you know I understand
where they're coming from and you know
like you said early is like it's a
business you know there's certainly
business and I'm probably understanding
that whole business decision thing so
I'm I didn't take too much offense to it
you know I was trying to get my head
down and wants to try and trade deadline
actually went by I was just ready to put
my head down get back to work and living
I got the impression from your comments
on the 17 weeks podcast that one of the
business aspects was a new team maybe
wanted you to redo your deal and you
said hey wait I I fought for this thing
I'm not redoing anything if you want to
trade for me you're taking my contract
was that a big part of those talks yeah
that was definitely a huge part you know
because I and you know I understand how
no day's work you know everything was
the fact I had to know actually saw the
whole year to kind of get into I wanted
to get today you know our depth and
couldn't like you know retracts on it
you know
I'm still trying to set myself up with
my family up down the line so I made
sure that you know everything charts
they attacking
we both would know myself and whoever
team what it got me we both became
winners out of it not just still all
right I'm not gonna ask you which team
it came the closest with but what color
helmet would you be wearing right now if
it had happened hey what's the biggest
difference between Mike Tomlin the guy
who was your only NFL coach before this
year and Adam GaSe the guy who's your
coach now I'm the bigger differences uh
I think uh it's close close Tommen is
more of like people with defensive
minded you know it is rare when I had
like you know meetings and things like
that were first time I was sitting there
with us because he's always with the
defense you know he's more of a deviance
in my DNA coaching you know Adam GaSe is
really the total opposite office of
minded coach I spend a lot of time with
him cuz he's in all of our meetings
going on going over all the plays and
installs you know so that's really you
know the biggest difference baroque is
being offensive decent-minded
last question for you give me one thing
you miss about Pittsburgh oh I miss the
fans you know the fans or you know they
were great uh they always came out and
supported it was always kind of you know
behind me know so oh well I bet a lot of
my teammates too you know I had a great
friends over there so it was fun over
there you know so there's a lot of
things I miss about it you know but I'm
also being in New York now you know I'm
happy where I am
hey let me ask you one more real quick
one if you kept in touch with Antonio
Brown at all he's going through a rough
time he wants to get back in the league
what advice would you have for him kept
in touch with you know but you know I
think my biggest surprise to probably
like maybe like oh that's right but
that's what I do too much over social
media you know I mean I do I kind of
watch
that follows them and wants to hear what
you have to say so try to keep on a
pilot energy you know if you are on
social media and try out the post you
know negative things all right man great
advice and good luck today driving the
armored truck I'd give you some advices
of if I could I've never gotten within
10 feet of once so pop the clutch and
hope for the best at least it's big
right what can happen it's big rock
scissors paper
the armored trucks gonna win if it goes
haywire so good luck driving around in
that thing today levian we hope to talk
to you getting down the road what lovely
I appreciate it make sure everybody
follow social media today I'm giving out
cash with that point payday all right
man
Pepa coin calm we'll check it out we'll
check out your social media pages and
good luck with it
we're vote late
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports